a lot of excitement around the blue jay
debut of jose barrios boy this is
something special right here there is
numbers with the minnesota twins this
year in 20 starts
note the era a 3 48 his last start first
the twins on the 24
seven innings two runs none of them
earned of course no walks in that ball
game blue jays gave up a lot to get them
they're number two and number four
prospect
1-1 and this one is popped up down the
third baseline a long run
and what a play boba [ __ ]
had to go a mile to make that catch and
he did it
the only one who was going to make that
play you know
he can flash some great plays
at time they were in the shift even the
outfield were
that's bo right there at the top of your
screen look how far he has to go and at
the last second
curve his glove in and just snatch it
out of the air snow cone it if you will
to get a very dangerous hitter for out
number one beautiful
and jose barrio says yeah i'll take some
of that
the o1 is hit to left center field
guriel
into the alley and he made the catch
so some hard hit balls but no damage
done and jose barrios's first inning as
a blue jay
brad keller who had a tremendous month
of july
and the royals will lean on him today as
they try to avoid a sweep
that pitch ate up springer that's
probably where mike miner wanted
the first pitch of the game yesterday
you want to be able to come in there
like that look at the life on that that
two seamer just took off
it started way on the outside part of
the plate and look at the late movement
in
shocked him he was like man i'm not
trying to get out of the way of that
and sets that up what a nice setup job
that was by keller
a broken back ground ball back to the
mouth throw to second one on to first
two and as we mentioned another thing
marios does well
is field his position and that was no
routine play with a broken back yeah he
is
he's hasn't won a gold glove but he's
athletic
enough to make those plays repeat your
delivery backhands it like a shortstop
and throws a strike to second base
0-2 got it
[Applause]
there's the curveball and his first
strikeout as a blue jay
[Applause]
1-1 and rounded up the middle of base
hit
wow what a pitch there's that great
natural cut that would get a nod of
approval from mariana rivera
better believe that that deserved a blue
kc pitch tracks we showed you exactly
where he wanted that so two on and two
out for
santiago espinal and there's a ground
ball to o'hern
so the blue jays strand two and at the
end of two no score
[Music]
one two to with mary field got it on his
hands again it's popped up burrillos
calling for it loudly and he'll make the
play
he had to have played shortstop at one
point
in his career somewhere that play he
made last inning on the double play
and then the pop-up right away we could
hear it all the way up here
sneaks a peek at santana over at first
and he got him to chase that one a big
strikeout of perez for out number two
2-2 and he got him
a nice job by barrios here in the third
and now back to the top of the order for
george springer who struck out on a
slider his first time up
right center field and well hit taylor
back can't make the catch
maguire around third coming home
springer on his way to third
and he is going to be caught in a
rundown but it is a double to drive in
the first run
of the afternoon sun shining in
as this one is lifted to left center it
is well hit
and off the wall i believe or is it
out yes it is out it was off the facing
of the lower deck it's a two-run homer
for marcus simeon and the blue jays go
up three to nothing
they are zeroing in on brad keller
meanwhile
i guess they have decided that uh
vladimir guerrero jr is a bit too much
of a nuisance not being in the lineup
and uh
they're just gonna uh kind of pin him
down on the far corner there and not let
him move
sit right here for a little bit sit
still
and enjoy the game
and that's going to be played by dozier
in the shortstop position with the shift
so that takes care of the missed play on
the ball hit by guriel but the blue jays
get three in the third
yankees are seven games back 2-2
a fastball on the outside corner strike
three called
dozier goes down looking and barrios has
struck out three straight
swinging to miss got him with a changeup
four consecutive strikeouts now
for jose barrios yeah with the curveball
with the fastball and now with the
change up to get
hurt so now santiago espinal rounded out
to first his first time up
this ball is well hit left field and
it's gone
santiago espinal with his second home
run
that is going to make his buddies at the
end of the bench
very happy he's get to he gets to wear
the home run jacket now after that blast
ground ball back to him and again he
makes a very nice defensive play
so the broken background ball the pop-up
on the mound and now a one hopper bag to
him and he's made all three
and beau likes to challenge himself with
a good fastball he's got a challenge
here
there you go dealing with the uh
the wall if you will like an outfielder
this time he has to deal with the
railing and
snow cones that one for a great catch
that way
that's how you get on tv dan aces are
loaded here two down
four nothing blue jays bottom five wow
fourth walk in a row and that one will
force in a run to make it five to
nothing
elvis martinez obviously there
still a lot of good players there
did he chase it yeah he did strikeout
number six
he's on the cusp of a pretty good
ovation from 15 000 people
he did it strikes him out number seven
six scoreless innings for jose barrios
in his blue jays debut royals have gone
an entire series without scoring with a
runner
in scoring position but olivares hits a
home run to left
to put an end to the shutout so he's
going to get a long look
after the jorge solaire trade and he has
two hits today that's his second home
run as a royal
finish this one off quick and looks like
that's the way it's gonna go
vizio unassisted and the blue chase will
win it and
sweep the royals and run their overall
winning streak to four